you look way better than when we used to
see each other opening anthony yeah opie
and anthony dude i was [ __ ]
going in there i just spoke to opie
yesterday he says hello i um
yeah opie and anthony well you were when
we were doing opium together you were
actively using cocaine and then you were
fingering um you were doing the
the oh orgasm meditation orgasm
meditation with the old ladies
yeah and then i was just rooting for the
new york islanders i was just going to
islanders games every night getting
tanked and then coming with a fat deer
face
theo used to sleep in the studio dude
that was good
you were dirt [ __ ] poor you came a
long ways
oh dude i mean and dude remember opening
up that was not that long ago
like 20 years 16 gym when i got away
started then he got an opium gym so
that's longer than five years ago no but
i wouldn't be long in this just five
years 2016 2017.
we didn't have [ __ ] theo didn't have
[ __ ] in 20 right 2016-2017 i had
erectile dysfunction
a cocaine problem i wouldn't say problem
i would say
you can't remember the episode you came
in it was miyu shirad karu
how about that all those things we used
to do two out of the four people are
always being in studio are legit dead
they are carl and who carl ruiz chatter
carl reese uh who's dead
yeah the the cuban chef and then vic
henley where would you guys do the show
at from siriusxm from
opie it was opening new york opinion jim
norton yeah yeah right midtown manhattan
yeah carl wheeze died in his sleep and
then vic henley died in the beginning of
quarantine man
well you two were carrying the torch so
let's hey both of you tighten up
china what are you still characterizing
we live
dude yeah i'm just saying i don't know
if you need to tell us because
you don't know how apparently how the
math of we live works
we are live
who's going to live longer hold on let's
go out to the three of us
let's get a look at carl ruiz and see
what is he most
likely 900 in disguise right there
okay okay bang i almost actually am
believing that carl wheeze isn't dead
he just came alive as president yeah
dude now he's [ __ ] learning disabled
carl ruiz
they broke up right they broke up uh uh
their show broke up and then opie and
jim norton were doing it and then opie
left
that show or something happened with the
contract was up and now jim norton does
the show with sam roberts
uh still on uh whatever the new series
i've been on there yeah
jim and sam jim's one of my favorite
people but opium anthony was like
opening anthony in a way
i mean howard starting howard's turn but
open anthony was kind of like that
original podcast thing where it was like
they were just saying doing whatever i
loved
but on the radio yeah well you would
have there would be no patrice o'neill
or you wouldn't have heard of patrice
o'neills of um the robert kelly's
all those guys blew up i i never got to
go
i remember going in there dude and it
was like the biggest
thing ever it was like you got to go in
it first of all you walked into the
building there's like business people
outside
there's some guy like jewish building
major celebrities going in and out like
of series live we were in the elevator
once with channing tatum like you're
just like
because they're all doing other shows
but opium dude that's like and i don't
know if that'll ever come back like that
man because siriusxm is [ __ ] close
it's been closed
since no one listens and they're not
open
i don't know see it's weird it's not
though
they don't listen in the middle of the
country they listen in the middle of the
country they listen to some of the truck
drivers [ __ ]
because they they have somebody has to
be listening because they make real
money millions of dollars
you know who listens to them every time
you get a rental car they count those as
subscriptions
that's what nobody's really listening
but they but they pay
they pay howard stern that's a good
point then let go my boy jason ellis
right they pay howard stern
yeah they yeah they pay they wasn't a
podcast and that's why howard stern's
uploading this [ __ ] on youtube now i
can't believe they let go to ellis man
ellis
held it down for them for so freaking
long man yeah dude that was the one
picture this is theo this i remember
this day was on full cocaine because he
was
trying to get some off daryl strawberry
oh wow
look at his face on his face his nostril
and hot yeah see if you zoom in i mean
his jaws like that he's got you know
that's what it is so yeah dude strong my
mouth was closed according to me in my
head
every time i see him i bleed in his
presence just in case he needs it
he looks very ever you would always know
theo was on was on coke the night before
because it'd be 8 15 in the morning he'd
already be sweating
he'd just be fully sweating just
dripping off his chin in the chair
yeah like i was at equinox dude those
are some of this
because the podcast world all this stuff
is great and there's obviously way more
money here and
and blows it up but i remember it was
like fun taking the train going in
then we would do the show hang out after
yeah they had somebody in
like a closeted let's be in no offense
if anybody's lesbian but
um they had like a cl downstairs and
they would like
char like they had to like get your
identification for you you'd always be
late
like [ __ ] just figure it
[Music]
it's out king of nice games